Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Zülal Solak
Bugün sizinle bir kaygımı
paylaşmaya geldim.
Aslında bu kaygının sadece beni ve
bu ülkedeki 700 ila 800 bin kişiyi değil,
bu salonda bulunan her birinizi
teker teker ilgilendirdiğini sanıyorum.
Şu önümüzdeki çok kısa zaman dilimi
içerisinde, vicdanlarınıza ulaşabilir
ve sizi harekete geçirebilirsem,
benim için ne mutlu.
Konuşmak istediğim konu,
aslında LGBTİ hakları ile ilgili.
Yani; Lezbiyen, Gey, Biseksüel,
Trans ve İntersekslerle ilgili.
Şimdi benim son otuz yıldır,
adli bilimlerin olay yeri inceleme,
DNA analizleri, uyuşturucu analizleri,
delil toplama gibi konularda çalışan bir
biyokimya profesörü olduğumu
bilenler, LGBTİ hakları dendiğinde,
ne anlatacağımı yaklaşık
tahmin etmiş olabilirler.
Örneğin bu vatandaşlarımız,
çok ciddi şiddet ve kimi
zaman da ölümle tehdit edilen
ve hatta öldürülen kişilerdir
ve böyle büyük bir risk taşırlar.
Daha önce kendileri tehdit
edilir, ölümle tehdit edilir ya da,
bu konuda herhangi bir ipucu alırlarsa
aynı şekilde polisten de
şiddet göreceklerin korktukları için,
polise gitmezler,
bu nedenle de korunamazlar.
Tanıklar da, benzer şekilde
genellikle onların yakınları olduğundan,
yine damgalanmaktan korkar, intikamdan
çekinir ve gidip ifade vermezler.
Size bu konuşmamda, zaman zaman
aydınlatılamayan cinayetlerinin
nasıl soruşturulması icap edildiğini
veyahutta, DNA bankalarının bir türlü
kurulamayaşının ne kadar zararlı olduğunu
anlatmaya gelmedim.
Size, ne bu cinayetlerin
aydınlatılamayışından,
ne de önlenemeyişinden aslında devletin
sorumlu olduğunu anlatmaya gelmedim.
Aslında konunun benim için
bir hayli eski, başka bir nedeni var.
Ve bunu ilk defa, topluluk önünde
dillendireceğim için
gerçekten bir hayli heyecanlıyım.
Bundan çok uzun yıllar önce,
bir kış gecesi,
masada oturmuş çalışıyordum.
O, biraz ötemde, dolapla kanepe
arasında ayakta durmuş bana bakıyordu.
Durumda bir gariplik olduğu belliydi.
Nitekim biraz sonra aynen
konuşmaya başladı ve dedi ki,
başka birine aşığım
ve evdekiler bunu bilmiyor.
O anda ne diyeceğimi bilemedim.
Nasıl olur diye düşündüm kendi kendime.
Yıllardır nasıl olur da bunu anlamadım.
Kim, diye sordum,
sanki bir önemi varmışçasına.
Bana bir isim söyledi, hiç cevap vermedim.
Ama o andan itibaren,
hayatımın bütün gidişi değişti.
Çünkü adını verdiği bir erkekti.
Her nasılsa akıllılık edip nasıl,
neden, ne zamandan beri gibi
saçma sapan sorular sormadım.
Daha sonra bu konuyu da
çok fazla konuşmadık.
Kısa bir zaman diliminden
sonra da birbirimizden koptuk
ve bir daha da hiç rastlaşmadık.
Ama o gün ona, sadece teşekkür ettim.
Beni böylesine yakın bulup
bu çok gizli sırrını
benimle paylaştığı için.
Çünkü aslında ben o tarihlerde,
birine yazılan şiirin
ya da birisi için yapılan bir bestenin,
aslında kimin için yazıldığını
ve kimin için bestelendiğini
insanın en yakınlarına dahi,
anneye babaya kardeşlere
dahi söyleyemeyeceğinin,
bir eşcinselin gündelik hayatta
yaşadığı korkunç üzüntüyü bilmiyordum.
Daha sonraki yıllarda, elbette bu
konuda bir sürü şey okumaya çalıştım.
Ama aynı teşekkürü
10 yıl sonra bir başka erkeğe daha yaptım.
Benim üç kez evlenip ayrıldığımı
bilenler, bunu onlardan biri sanabilir.
Yok, bu seferki
bir erkek arkadaşım değildi.
Kuzey Amerika'nın çok ünlü ve büyük bir
polis kriminal labarotuvarında
çalışan bir bilgisayar uzmanıydı.
Bir kongrede tanışmıştık,
ikinci gördüğümde benim
yanıma geldi ve dedi ki,
sizinle bir sırrımı paylaşmak
istiyorum ve anlattı.
İkinci kez şaşırmadım.
Cesaret bulmuş olacak ki,
çalıştığı yere de bu durumu söyleyince,
teşkilattan ayrılmak zorunda kaldı.
Üçüncü kez karşılaştığımızda,
tanımakta bir hayli zorlandım.
Gerçi biraz yaşlanmış ve zayıflamıştı.
Başka bir şehre taşınmış,
üniversiteye girmiş;
bir akademisyen olarak,
başarılı bir akademisyen olarak
hayatını sürdürmekteydi.
Ama daha da önemlisi,
beyaz uzun ipeksi saçlarını, ensesinde
toplamış zarif ve hoş bir kadındı.
Şimdi,
daha sonraki yaşamımda,
aralarında hocalarım, öğrencilerim,
meslektaşlarım da olan pek çok LGBTİ ile
yaşamım kesişti.
Bundan bir süre önce,
toplumları bölen,
tartışmaları her zaman açmaza
götüren bu konuyla ilgili olarak,
BBC'de bir araştırmanın
sonuçları yayınlandı.
Bu araştırma, Hollandalılar
tarafından yapılmış bir araştırma,
ama ondan önce size,
bu sorunu, dünyada ülkeleri
birbirinden nasıl ayırdığına dair
bir iki örnek vermek istiyorum.
Mesela California valisi,
herhangi bir bilimsel
ve tıbbi temeli olmadığı için,
eşcinsel gençlerin tedavisini
yasaklamış durumda.
Ama buna karşılık, dünyanın en kalabalık
gey onur yürüyüşlerini düzenlemekle ünlü
Brezilya'da, her yirmi dört
saatte bir gey öldürülüyor.
Bir İngiliz polis karakolu,
göndere dayanışmanın işareti olarak
gökkuşağı bayrağı asarken,
IŞİD militanları, eşcinsel gibi
davranarak eşcinsel avına çıkıyor.
Onları Irak'ta,
Suriye'de, Libya'da avlıyor,
yüksek duvarlardan aşağı atarak öldürüyor,
belki ölmemişlerdir diyerekten de
halkın gözünün önünde taşlıyorlar.
İşte böylesine çelişkili bir dünya
içerisinde yaşarken,
BBC bu araştırmayı yayınladı.
Bu araştırma, dünyanın değişik
ülkelerinde, bu arada Türkiye'de de
eşcinsellikle ilgili toleransı
ölçebilmek için bazı sorular içermiş.
Bunlardan bir tanesi de, ''Eşcinsel
komşu ister misiniz?'' diye bir soru.
Bizim ülkemizde cevap veren vatandaşların
%85'i, yani 7 kişiden 6'sı, hayır demiş.
Aynı soruyu, psikoloji bölümü
öğrencilerime sordum.
Kızlar gerçi biraz daha olaya pozitif
bakıyorlardı ama, onların da çoğu
yine erkekler gibi,
hayır demeyi tercih etti.
Ama evet diyenlerin ortak
çok önemli bir noktası vardı.
O da; bir LGBTİ birey tanımış, konuşmuş
ya da birlikte çalışmış olmalarıydı.
Şimdi, insanlar gerçekten tanımadıkları
şeylerden korkarlar.
Yüzyıllardır tarih boyunca hep yabancı
olandan, bilinmezden korkmuşlardır.
Korku nefreti doğurur, nefret de şiddeti.
Şimdi,
bu araştırmanın dolayısıyla sonuçlarını,
kısmen de olsa anlayabiliyorum.
Ama anlayamadığım önemli bir şey var;
o da Türkiye'nin şu anda,
bu araştırma sonuçlarına göre,
dünyada eşcinsellere en hoşgörüsüz ülkeler
kategorisi içerisine sokulmuş olması.
Bizimle aynı kategoride olan diğer
ülkeler; Zimbabve, Gana, Fas, Uganda,
Irak, Güney Kore gibi ülkeler.
Aslında bunların, neredeyse tamamında,
eşcinsellik cezalandırılan bir suç.
Halbuki bizim ülkemizde,
son dört padişahımızın babası
Abdülmecid zamanında,
yani bundan 157 yıl önce,
eşcinsellik suç olmaktan çıkartılmış.
Şimdi uluslararası lezbiyen ve
gey birliği ILGA'nın sayılarına göre,
dünya genelinde 2 milyar 800 milyon
kadar LGBTİ birey yaşıyor.
Şimdi, bu az önceki kategori içerisinde
bulunan Türkiye ile ilgili olarak,
bazı şeyleri içime sindiremiyorum.
Çünkü benim ülkem; cumhurbaşkanı
eşcinsellerin domuzdan da, köpekten de
daha aşağılık olduğunu söyleyen
bir Zimbabve ile aynı kategoride olamaz.
Ya da eşcinsellerin düzeltilmesi için;
erkeklerin zorla evlendirildiği,
kadınların ırzına geçildiği bu
ülkeyle aynı kategoride olamaz.
Ya da Irak gibi, polislerin ve milislerin,
aslında yasalarda suç olmadığı halde,
birer birer kadın ve erkek lezbiyenleri
avladığı bir ülkeyle, aynı kategoride
olamaz.
Çünkü bu ülkede,
çok önemli bazı kararlar alınmış durumda.
Mesela ''sapkın'' söyleminin, aslında
anayasaya aykırı olduğunu ve bir suç,
nefret söylemi olduğunu karara
bağlamış olan bir anayasa mahkememiz var.
Aslında eşcinsel öğretmenin işten
atılmasını, hukuka aykırı bulmuş olan bir
danıştayımız var ve 17 yaşındaki oğlunun
başına kurşun sıkan ve bir eşcinseli
öldürmek için bunu yapan babaya
ağırlaştırılmış, amcalara müebbet hapis
cezası vermiş olan mahkemelerimiz var.
Zabıtlara,
cinsel tercih yerine cinsel yönelim
ibaresini yazdırabilmiş savcılar var.
Dolayısıyla Türkiye'de, bizim bu Zimbabve
ile ya da Ruanda ile ya da Gana'yla aynı
kategoride olmamız doğrusu içimize
sindirilebilir bir hadise değil.
Elbette Türkiye ve dünya, LGBTİ hakları
noktasına böylesine kolay gelmedi.
Özellikle eğlence sektöründe çalışanlar,
bundan çok çok ağır şiddet gördüler,
hatta iş yerleri tahrip edildi ve kadına
benzeyebilmek için de duvar adı verilen
bir ameliyatlar oldular.
Bu ameliyatlarla penisleri kesildi,
fakat yerine vajina yapılmadı.
Türkiye böylesine zor bir süreçten geçti.
Şurasını unutmayalım ki,
İstanbul Belediye Başkanının bir onur
yürüyüşüne katılması ve onun önünde
bir gökkuşağı bayrağı sallaması için
daha çok uzun yıllar var.
Yani bir New York valisi
ya da Toronto belediye başkanı
gibi hareket etmesini beklemiyorum.
Ama, bundan on yıl önce sadece otuz
kişinin katıldığı onur yürüyüşlerine
bugün on binler katılmakta.
Her ne kadar, başbakan yardımcımız
bir uluslararası platformda,
eşcinsellere yönelik nefret
suçlarının soruşturulduğunu
ve ceza indirimine
gidilmediğini söylese bile,
bu her ne kadar güzel bir söylem olsa da,
aslında içini doldurabilmiş olduğumuz
bir söylem değil, bu doğru değil.
Çünkü bu insanlarımız, gündelik
yaşamlarının her alanında; iş yerinde,
okulda, hastanede, çarşıda, pazarda
sürekli olarak ayrımcılığa uğruyor
ve homofobik ve transfobik
söylemle karşı karşıya kalıyorlar.
Bu insanlar büyük bir depresyon
ve anksiyete sıkıntısının içine düşüyor
ve hatta, alkol kullanıyor,
uyuşturucu madde kullanıyorlar.
Ve bu alkol ve madde kullanımı,
LGBTİ bireyler arasındaki oranı,
toplumun diğer gruplarından
çok çok daha yüksek.
İş bulamamak, okuyamamak onları
giderek yoksulluğa itebiliyor
ve bu yoksulluk da kimi zaman, hırsızlık
ve seks işçiliğinden
başka bir çözüm bırakmıyor.
Hâlbuki, Dünya Sağlık Örgütü'nün
17 Mayıs 1990'daki tarihi kararı,
yani eşcinselliğin bir hastalık
olmadığına dair o tarihi kararının
üzerinden tam 25 yıl geçti.
Ve dünyanın diğer ülkelerinde,
Dünya Sağlık Örgütü olsun,
Birleşmiş Milletler olsun,
bu konuyla ilgili bütün tavsiyelerine uyan
her türlü yasal düzenlemeyi
yapan ülkelerinde,
hatta resmi ve dini evliliklerini dahi
tasvip eden 17 ülkesinde de yine LGBTİ
bireyler ciddi bir biçimde nefret söylemi
ve nefret suçlarıyla karşı karşıyalar.
Örneğin, Türkiye son yedi yılda trans
cinayetleri açısından Avrupa birincisi.
Otuz beş ölümüz var.
Bunun yanı sıra,
Avrupa'da aynı zaman diliminde
öldürülen transların sayısı 57.
Avrupa'nın birçok ülkesi,
çok gelişmiş yasalara sahip.
Ama, gördüğünüz gibi
mesele sadece yasalarda değil.
Çünkü yüzyıllardır süregelen
bir korkudan söz ediyoruz.
Yüzyıllardır süregelen eşcinselliğin tıpkı
veba gibi ortadan kaldırılması gereken
bir hastalık olduğundan söz ediyoruz.
Yüzyıllardır süregelen, eşcinselliğin
inançlara aykırı olduğu,
dinlere aykırı olduğu, günah olduğu;
üremeye yaramadığı için,
doğaya aykırı olduğu inancından geliyoruz.
Elbette herkesin kültürüne, geleneğine,
inançlarına saygım sonsuz.
Ama bugün artık doğada,
beş yüzden fazla türün;
kuştan balığa, ördekten
kafası dikenli solucana kadar,
eşcinsel davranışlarda
bulunduğunu biliyoruz.
Hepsi olmasa bile, çok büyük bir
bölümünü izah da edebiliyoruz.
Şimdi hâl böyle olunca, tabii ki
meselenin doğaya aykırı olup olmadığı
noktasında bir sorgunun
kalmadığını gösteriyor.
Doğa, eşcinsel davranışı
defaatle gösteren bir sistem.
Neden olduğunu anlayabilmiş değiliz,
ama böyle bir olgu var.
Şimdi, 66 yıldır geçerli olan bir
beyanname var; İnsan Hakları Beyannamesi.
Burada; bütün insanların, onur ve haklar
açısından özgür ve eşit doğduğuna
karar vermiş, kabul etmiş
ve imza atmış durumdayız.
Güven içinde özgürce yaşam hakkı
olduğuna imza atmış durumdayız.
Bütün insanlar diyoruz.
Yani bir bölümü ya da bazıları değil.
Yani dış görünüşünü veya sevdikleri
kişiyi beğenmediğimiz kişiler değil,
hepsi için bu haklar geçerli.
Ve önemli olan,
devlet temel haklar açısından
hiç kimseyi mahrum edemez.
Çünkü demokrasi
çoğunluğun yönetiminden öte bir şeydir;
demokrasi, cinsiyet kimliği
ve cinsel yönelim açısından
herkese eşit haklar vermek
ve ayrımcılıktan korumak zorundadır.
Eksik yasalar değiştirilebilir,
ama önemli olan zihniyeti değiştirmektir,
zihniyet sadece bilimin ışığında olabilir.
Bilim bize bugün,
DNA üzerindeki üç bölgede,
öncelikli olarak erkek eşcinselliğini
mutlaka etkileyen
bölgeler olduğunu göstermekte.
DNA üzerindeki üç bölgenin başında,
Xq12 kromozomu geliyor.
Bu bölgelerde çok sayıda gen var.
İşte henüz hangi genlerin
eşcinselliğe yol açtığını bilmiyoruz.
Ama, bunların kuşkusuz çok
yakın bir zamanda adı da konacak.
Buradan da anlaşılan,
eşcinselliğin genetik bir boyutu var.
Buna ek olarak, DNA üzerine metil
gruplarının eklenmesiyle meydana çıkan
bazı değişiklikler de
cinsel yönelimi etkiliyor.
Biz buna epigenetik diyoruz.
Dış etkenlerin meydana
getirdiği epigenetik değişiklikler.
Ama dış etkenler dediğim zaman,
sakın ha dominant bir anne,
evde olmayan bir baba
ya da çocuğun cinsel istismara uğramasını
eşcinselliği tetiklediğini zannetmeyin.
Bunlar moleküler düzeyde değişiklikler ve
daha anne karnında başlayan değişiklikler.
İşte durum şu;
her ne kadar moleküler olarak
henüz eşcinselliği tam olarak
tanımlayabilmiş değilsek de,
şurası muhakkak ki,
davranışı belki ağır cezalarla
değiştirebiliriz ama,
yönelimi hiçbir şekilde
etkilememiz mümkün değil.
Cinsel yönelim ne tercih edilebilir,
ne özendirilebilir,
ne öğretilebilir,
ne seçilebilir.
Şimdi şu kapıdan çıktıktan sonra,
aslında aşağılanan, ayrımcılığa
uğrayan, oturacak ev, gidecek iş,
okuyacak okul bulamayan,
intihara depresyona kimi zaman da
ölüme sürüklenen insanların,
ananız babanız, kardeşiniz, çocuğunuz,
öğretmeniniz, öğrenciniz,
ama daha önemlisi
kendiniz olduğunu düşünün.
Ve lütfen bu kapıdan çıktıktan sonra,
gidin insanlarımızın beynindeki
bu ön yargıları silmeye çalışın.
Ve nasıl çocuk istismarı,
çocuklara bırakılacak bir mesele değilse,
kadın cinayetleriyle
kadınların başa çıkması mümkün değilse,
yani toplumun geneli bu her iki sorunla
mücadele etmek zorundaysa benzer şekilde,
LGBTİ haklarıyla ilgili olarak da,
hepimizin hep birlikte
mücadele etmesi gerekir.
Sizden beklediğim,
kapıdan dışarıya çıktığınızda,
insanlarımıza cinsel yönelimin
tabiatın içinde yaygın
bir biçimde tanık olunan
bir çeşitliliğin sonucu
olduğunu anlatmanız.
Sizden beklediğim,
insan olduğumuzu anlatmanız.
Ve her insanın hayatını yaşama
hakkı olduğunu ve her insanın,
istediğini sevme hakkı
olduğunu da onlara anlatmanız.
Sizi harekete geçirebildiysem,
ne mutlu bana.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)